it seems that anime these days has no
shortage of overpowered characters at
all I mean let's be real pick up a
random asically adaptation and chances
are you'll find an Opie character that's
a variation of a template in spite of
that non light novels also have their
fair share of overpowered characters and
will mostly focus on them for this
installment of vini tubes 2019 rewind
take note the characters here are
considered Opie in relation to their
shows universe so don't go expecting
here that everyone would be able to go
one on one with Goku or something then
again some of them might just have what
it takes
so despite what I just said we're
beginning this list with our one and
only Issyk I entry who better to open up
the list and the poster boy of quite
possibly 2019 s most polarizing and mean
worthy show re faretta they say what
doesn't kill you makes you stronger and
no one embodies that better than Hajime
Nagumo blessed with transmutation powers
once thought to be sucky in combat he
gets betrayed by his classmate and falls
down to his doom also everybody thought
putting his creativity and
resourcefulness to good use
he fights eats and claws his way out of
the Orcas labyrinth coming out a monster
of the abyss far more powerful than
everyone in the show seriously after his
initial struggles in the first arc
everything became a cakewalk right edgy
no fool me connect fusion throwing
hordes of monsters doesn't work at all
and after the first arc he acquires a
magical toolbox that allows him to store
his numerous crafted tools for every
situation Humvees motorcycles sniper
rifles mini guns piledrivers magical
artifacts you name it
coming off an impressive recent outing
is gorgon from fgo Babylonia Wow the
Avenger class is really made up of
overpowered beings despite OSHA Walker
Maru and Leonidas his best efforts they
failed to even bring the mighty Gorgon
down to even a critical condition even
two back-to-back noble phantasms that
cost the servants their lives were in
vain as Gorgon tanked everything without
a sweat truly a fitting performance for
a video game boss in the ultimate enemy
of the ark you thought the gap between
the demonic beasts and the goddess is
big well how about the gap between this
serpent God and the rest of the
characters insurmountable and
immeasurable you'd wonder what could
possibly stop Gorgons rampage had she
gone all out in attacking you rook to be
fair we have yet to see Gorgon fight
Gilgamesh but given her performance I
don't really like our golden boys
chances
up next is our newest threaten the my
hero academia anime overhaul is it a
coincidence that we're still at the
third entry but already have two masters
over matter on the list smart people
would know that control over matter and
form is one of the most broken abilities
around and my hero fans need to look no
further from the remorseless overhaul
the latest and the greatest threat of
the post all might worlds as strong as
he seems given a quirk that allows his
full command of matter he can choose to
kill people by disassembling them as
well as healing people through the same
method worst of all he can even merge
his body with others gaining access to
other quirks in terms of pure strength
overhaul may not be MHA universes
strongest villain however he said to me
makes a case for being one of the most
dangerous ones out there facing him no
one and nowhere is safe as even the
environment becomes the villains deadly
weapon
the mighty captain and father of tour
fiends made a name for himself in the
world of Finland saga a professional
mercenary and unrepentant killer tours
is a mighty warrior who gives up his
life in order to live in peace along
with a vow to stop killing despite his
newfound pacifism tours remains a
powerful fighter given his strength and
skill with combat even fighting
barehanded doesn't seem to be a handicap
even unarmed he's able to easily take on
Oscar lads mercenaries even more amazing
is that he did so without killing anyone
when he has the capability to do so it's
no exaggeration to call tours the
world's best warrior as far as bin land
song is concerned I mean even talk he'll
admitted tours was much stronger than
him no one can even get close to his
level past and present
[Applause]
moonwalking his way into the list is
Mouzon at number six all jokes aside can
we sit back and appreciate moves on for
a bit what we're looking at here is the
ancestor and origin of all demons that
have been hounding humanity for years
all it takes for him to start spitting
out demons in order to avoid showing his
hand for generations is a scratch one
thing that demon slayer does really well
is establishing the pecking order
between humans and demons Slayers are
typically above regular demons but even
the pillars find themselves having more
difficulties against the elite demons
known as upper moons now imagine how
strong Musa their creator really is the
reason Mazon isn't higher on the list is
because we've yet to see much of him in
combat killing off the lower moons is
one thing but wait till you see the
total package once the anime inevitably
catches up to the manga night
invulnerability insane regeneration
evolving abilities adaptability and more
you have to read ahead to find out what
Mouzon is really capable of
[Applause]
humanity's strongest soldier makes a
long-awaited appearance on the list ever
since a season one of attack on Titan
badassness seems to use out of Levi he's
not called humanity strongest soldier
for nothing and this latest season of
attack on Titan cements that not to take
credit from the rest of the survey
corpse but if we're going to go by
showing his straight up combat Levi's by
far the strongest and most overpowered
among the humans he's the only one able
to defeat one of the big three Titans
all by himself technicalities aside
that's no little feet and when you look
at how he won his first fight against
the Beast Titan you can say that he's
truly above the rest in terms of combat
it's not a fight against the Beast Titan
it's a showcase an exhibition courtesy
of everyone's favorite Titan Slayer
[Applause]
[Music]
and number four is the newest menace to
the seas Kaido we've already talked
about Kaido in a previous video and we
all know what he's capable of his scene
of crashing into kid pirates base set
the tone really for a first appearance
however how does he really stack with
the overall power level of the one piece
universe we've been given a million
references to kaido's superhuman
strength but with the Dragons of rival
we get our first look at his Devil
through powers as impressive as kaido's
inhumanely huge human form is his horned
fire-breathing self makes the pirate and
even more enigmatic and dangerous being
it ain't pretty for a plucky hero and he
has a long way to go if he has any hope
of finally one upping the strongest
creature in the world
come on scar you got yo
watching a couple of anime would have
told you not to underestimate the
unassuming boy with psychic powers
despite looking derpy and spaced out
mobs the most overpowered character in
the show he just needs the right trigger
and outcomes the world breaking powers
sealed within this boy the mere idea of
his psychic powers flaring up brings
fears of collateral damage and that's
not even taken into account his question
mark percentage form by far the most
unstable and unpredictable amongst his
multiple forms it's telling that pretty
much most of his early fights are curb
stomps it really makes you think that if
only mob has the green light to go
all-out and using his powers without
emotions holding him back he can easily
stop the competition around easily
even without refined techniques and all
that mob just beats the competition
through sheer power in the universe of
mob cycle 100 that's surely a recipe for
the title of most opie character
Oh
[Music]
ever thought having a power that can
manipulate life itself would be cool
ever thought of how broken that would be
well 2019 had a treat for you in the
form of Giorno Giovanna from JoJo's
Bizarre Adventure Jia knows a Requiem
stand spawned a lot of discussions and
jokes due to how ridiculously
overpowered it is who can blame the
people though
how could you top the ability to revert
the state of things and it's a vault
form gold experience gains the ability
to create death loops and wipe off
enemies will power the Jojo universe is
chock full of insane and crazy abilities
while none can match gold experienced in
the brokenness department the existence
of so many wild powers makes gold
experienced not as overpowered as it
could be in a vacuum
thus jana for short on topping the list
despite his powers
[Music]
she's such a mother she 2019 saw the
second season of one punch man and right
off the bat the top player on an
overpowered character list was cemented
by the old days Saitama steel and will
always be the most overpowered character
in his universe who else can solve
problems and defeat villains with just
one punch to be honest nothing much
needs to be said about him
Saitama will always be Saitama and with
it comes the very convenient ability to
destroy everything in his path with his
signature attack even with all the other
broken abilities by his fellow heroes I
don't think that anyone and anything can
match the hilarious simplicity and ease
of how Saitama makes short work of all
of his foes the race to becoming the
most opie character of 2019 was over
just as soon as it became and there we
have the top ten most overpowered
characters in 2019 so you think anyone
among them can go toe-to-toe with the
classic overpowered characters in anime
I'd love to hear your thoughts on that
one if you liked the content this week
hit the like button and don't forget to
subscribe and hit the bell so you can
get the latest updates trust me when I
say that we have a lot of things coming
your way and you're not gonna want to
miss them I'll see you next time on
Vinnie tube
[Music]
[Music]